merci mes chers collègues Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je vous présente tout
d'abord Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes
meilleurs vœux he pour cette année qui
s'ouvre une grande grande année pour
pour la Belgique ce sera aussi celle des
élections européenne c'est donc une
année particulièrement décisive pour
l'Union européenne et pour notre
commission bien sûr qui ens su les
développement on informe le Sénat et lui
permet de faire entendre sa voix à
Bruxelles souhaitons que les débats qui
vont s'ouvrir à l'occasion du prochain
scrutin européen permettent à nos
concitoyens comme à nos collègues
parlementaires de mieux s'approprier les
enjeux européens que la réponse
européenne au nombreux défis du moment
soit vraiment la leure il est heureux
que durant ce semestre menant aux
élections européennes la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne revienne à
la Belgique ce pays fondateur
et profondé comment un des pays
fondateurs bien sûr et est profondément
attaché à la construction européenne qui
a tant apporté au projet européen et je
remercie son Excellence Monsieur Jo
indek ambassadeur de Belgique à Paris
d'avoir accepté de venir aujourd'hui
présenter à notre commission les
priorités de cette présidence je le
disais avant- hier à namurù je
participais à la COSAC des présidents
donc je soulligne au passage
l'organisation absolument remarquable je
je le dis c'est vrai que on peut le dire
diplomatiquement souvent mais en tout
cas là franchement c'était c'était
vraiment un coup de maître bien que
votre présidence soit contrainte par les
prochaines élections européenne mais
aussi par votre calendrier électoral
national j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec mes
homologues je sais que nous pouvons
compter sur le professionnalisme et
l'esprit de compromis précieux des
Belges pour ce que ce semestre ne soit
pas perdu vous saurez faire avancer les
nombreux dossiers en instance achever
autant que possible l'actuel programme
législatif et préparer les défis futurs
je pense notamment à l'élaboration du
programme stratégique de l'Union
européenne pour les 5 ans à venir à la
préparation de l'Union aux futurs
élargissement envisagé et ça a été très
abordé à la coszak ou encore à la
révision du cadre financier pluriannuel
et des politique commune les rapporteurs
de la commission vous interrogeront sans
doute à ce propos pour ma part avant de
vous céder la parole je veux faire part
de ma préoccupation au regard de la
défiance envers l'Europe que nous voyons
grandir dans de nombreux pays y compris
le nôtre
il me paraît essentiel de rapprocher
l'Union des citoyens je pense en
particulier à la nécessité de renforcer
les règles d'éthique et de transparence
au niveau européen à la suite de
l'affire dite du Qatar gate à cet égard
nous regrettons et je l'ai dit aussi à
Namur le manque d'ambition de la
Commission européenne dans ce domaine si
important pour la confiance des citoyens
dans les institutions européenne est-ce
que cette question sera une priorité
pour la présidence belge monsieur monie
l'ambassadeur c'est à vous Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je propose d'avoir un
propos libre en tout cas par rapport aux
questions que je vous ai posé puis après
nous laisserons à la fois nos
rapporteurs et et les sénateurs présents
vous poser des questions en sachant que
nous avons une contrainte qui est celle
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement et nous devons finir la
séquence vers 14h entre 14h50 et
14h55 c'est à
vous merci
beaucoup
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur juste pour vous dire que
cette réunion est captée en audiovisuel
donc diffusée sur le site du
Sénat tout à fait merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président dire je suis très
content d'être ici je dire et dire hon
ait également de pouvoir présenter dire
le programme de la présidence belge de
l'Union européenne dire devant vous euh
c'est ve dire la première fois que je
passe à une aition dire au Parlement
même pas au Parlement belge dire
euh les diplomates ne sont pas conviés
donc dire ça c'est également marque de
d'intérêt de la part dire des instances
veut dire du pouvoir législatif veut
dire euh pour dire cette étape
importante euh je suis accompagné par
deux collaboratrices je veut dire dire
ma conseillre Europe et également
au madame tomich qui se voilà tout à
fait et ve dire voilà on a présenté un
un dire un slidhow dire dire en quelque
sorte pour faciliter les les les les
débats euh et voilà euh je vous propose
de faire d'abord vous dire une petite
dire introduction et puis par après on
pourrait fait comme vous avez suggéré
parler un peu et je suis conscient du
fait que vous êtes attentendu à 15h pour
un autre un autre événement donc je ve
dire euh pour pour la Belgique c'est la
13e fois que nous allons occuper cette
présidence de l'Union européenne dire
j'espère que c'est ce chiffre nous porte
pas malheur
euh et c'est à un moment critique que
nous allons nous allons le faire ve dire
d'abord à cause des circonstances
mondiales ve dire B il y a l'invasion
russe ve dire en en Ukraine la situation
au Gaza veut dire le changement
climatique veut dire la désinformation
veut dire euh et alors qui fait que je
ve dire
ben les euh l'actualité européenne
pourrait être
également déterminé par des événements
qui nous euh nous tombent dessus euh
2èement ve dire à un moment de la fin de
la législature européenne dire nous
sommes en fin de mandat dire
d'ailleurs on aura les élections dire le
9 juin c'est dire euh en France ce
seront des des élections européennes
dire en Belgique ce seront des on aura
la totale dire les élections européennes
nationales régionales et en octobre on
aura également les municipales donc vous
allez voir c'est la
totale c'est qui euh
euh crée également des des
développements intéressante ve dire au
niveau de politique interne belge
euh nous travaillons évidemment sur ve
dire ce qui nous est laissé par le la
présidence européenne dire pardon la
présidence espagnole ve dire et là ve
dire on est très content de pouvoir voir
que dire les Espagnols dire ont pu quand
même dire avancer dans une grande partie
des dossiers je veux dire afin de
pouvoir offrir alors quels sont nos
grands objectifs dire avant de les
détailler dans
dans dire un peu plus tard c'est dire
monsieur le Président vous avez parlé de
ça dire cette connexion avec entre
l'Europe et ses citoyens donc dire nous
pensons de le faire dire au niveau de le
faire de d'avoir d'offrir une meilleure
protection belge meilleure protection
aux citoyens européens de renforcer dire
la coopération non seulement ve dire
intraeuropéenne mais également dire avec
nos partenaires à l'extérieur de
préparer notre avenir commun en mettant
des jalons du débat futur et de préparer
le cycle législatif suivant de 2024 à
2029 et tout cela en montrant notre
soutien indéfectible à l'Ukraine dire où
là également il y a plusieurs dire
étapes
importantes duquel on doit décider dire
euh dans les mois à venir alors ve
dire pour cela nous le faisons ve dire à
travers de de six
thématiques qui sont dire dans la
première et la défendre l'État de droit
la démocratie l'unité dans l'Union
européenne renforcer notre compétitivité
poursuivre une transition écologique
juste renforcer notre agenda social et
sanitaire protéger les personnes et les
frontières et promouvoir l'Europe alors
ce qui concerne ve dire la première
thématique c'est défendre ve dire l'état
de droit et la démocratie l'unité et là
il est primordial de continuer à à
promouvoir et défendre le respect des
droits fondamentaux l'État de droit et
les valeurs
démocratique est également important de
de continuer à investir dans
l'autonomisation et l'inclusion des
citoyens et surtout les jeunes à travers
une éducation qualitative et davantage
de mobilité et des
Sports le pluralisme de garantir
également dire la pluralisme de le
pluralisme des médias la transformation
numérique et le lien avec la culture
dont on
a besoin et qui est tellement divers en
Europe en renforçant ve dire notre
compétitivité ve dire nous envisageons
de le faire en accordant une priorité à
la compétitivité
et à la politique industrielle en
donnant des garanties sur les conditions
de concurrence équitables non seulement
pour les grandes sociétés mais aussi
pour les PME et d'assurer je dir un
cadre réglementaire cohérent stable et
simplifié nous devons également veiller
à la création d'un écosystème numérique
durable innovant et
résilient sera égalementire consolider
le marché intérieur entre autres celui
des marchés des capitaux et celui de
l'énergie et l'avenir industriel de
l'Union européenne en réduisant la
dépendance dans des secteurs critiques
avec une attention particulière à notre
autonomie stratégique et non seulement
dire au niveau des matèr matières
premières stratégiques mais aussi de
production
alimentaire en faisant cela nous devons
également conférer un grand un plus
grand rôle à la recherche et
l'innovation et faire attention à un
marché de
travail équilibré pour augmenter les
taux d'emploi par une formation
continue tout cela nous devons le faire
également dire en poursuivant cette
transition écologique
juste où où il y a une place centrale à
la transition énergétique accélérée et
inclusive en assurant un accès favorable
aux citoyens et entreprises et garantir
une sécurité
d'approvisionnement en garantissant dire
également la la sécurité dire de notre
de notre approvisionnement dire tout en
gardant la neutralité climatique comme
objectif pour cela il faudra accroître
nos investissements en faveur d'un
réseau énergétique intégré et adapté aux
évolutions futures et au niveau climat
faudra également une attention à à
l'économie circulaire et une gestion
durable de
l'eau pour renforcer
dire le la partie sociale et
sanitaire de l'Union européenne dire il
faudra que dire et là dire la Belgique
dire essayera de de faire doter l'Union
européenne d'un programme
ambitieux social pour favoris une
société européenne plus inclusive plus
égalitaire et plus juste en renforçant
le dialogue social de prémouvoir une
mobilité équitable de la main- d'œuvre
défendre la la santé mentale au travail
et accès à une protection sociale
durable pour cela dire il y a un fort
plédoyer ve dire de la part ve dire des
ministres belges euh
d'un pldoyer dire pour une action
européenne commune en faveur d'un
logement dire décent et abordable pour
tous et de renforcer dire la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en médicen
d'ailleurs une première étape a été dire
lancée hier et une meilleure gestion des
médicaments abordables avec une
stratégie pour accroître les effectifs
dans les secteurs de la santé et des
soins qui où on constate actuellement
dire des pénueries de personnel don
pas mal de
pays faudrait également venir protéger
les individus et les frontières et là
dire la première priorité viendrait au
traitement du dessier législatif en
suspent dire associé au nouveau pacte
européen sur la migration et l'asile
dire vous savez que ve dire dans les
derniers jours de décembre la présidence
espagnole dire a eu un accord et donc il
revient à la Belgique de euh ve dire
euh de faire ve dire de de terminer le
trilogue et de terminer dire également
le le traitement parlementaire au
Parlement européen avant la décision du
Parlement
européen éèement dire renforcer la
dimension extérieure de notre politique
en matière d'asile et
immigration euh avec un partenariat
mutuellement bénéfique je veut dire euh
avec tous les pays
dire dont sont issu des grosses ve dire
dire vague de
d'immigration il faudra également
dire lutter contre la criminalité
organisée avec une prévention une
répression du terrorisme et de
l'extrémisme
violent mais également dire au niveau
dire de tout ce qui est veut dire traite
de Dra dire vel dire de drogue veut dire
le trafic de drogue ve dire et trait
humain il faut continuer également la
discussion sur l'avenir de la sécurité
et la défense européenne dire avec un
accent sur la consolidation de la base
industrielle et technologique de notre
industrie et finalement dire il nous
revient également dire de promouvoir ve
dire l'Europe mondiale face au défi
actuel nous vons poursuivre les efforts
pour renforcer notre résilience et notre
autonomie en défendant nos intérêts et
valeurs et utiliser et harmoniser tous
les outils à notre disposition que ce
soit au niveau sécuritaire dire
économique développement aide
humanitaire et politique
commerciale voilà dire quel est le le
calendrier comme vous savez ve dire la
Belgique étant dire un pays dire fédéral
ça veut dire que ve dire nous avons dire
des représentant ve dire des conseils
qui sont organisés dire au niveau dire
du de l'État fédéral également de l'État
fédéré donc il y a des ministres
régionaux qui vont présider au nom de la
Belgique certains conseils qui
sont et donc vous voyez là dire le
nombre de de
de de de conseils que nous avons il y a
43 plus de conseils formels à Bruxelles
qui sont sont présidés en fait ve dire
euh
euh soit par ve dire le Conseil européen
est présidé par le président Michel le
président du Conseil européen je les
autres les autres conseils informels ve
dire sont ve dire surtout ve dire
présidés par dire euh la présidence
belge soit un ministre fédéral belge
soit un ministre régional belge qui
parle pour l'ensemble du gouvernement
belge et de la Belgique donc vous voyez
qu'il y a dire nous avons essayé dire
également de de concentrer ve dire le
plus des réunions donc la plupart des
réunions auront lieu à Bruxelles même
dire généralement dans les mêmes
bâtiments que ce soit dire autour de
Schumann ou au palais d'ekmont qui est
le palais dire qui enfin qui un autre
qui dors je dire et euh il y en a neuf
qui ont lieu au ve dire en région ve
dire là ve dire c'est plutôt pour
également mettre en valeur ve dire la
participation ve dire de nos régions
dire et de réfléter dire la structure
ou la nature fédérale de de notre
pays
euh alors ve dire pour euh il y a déjà
dire des sommets qui ont informels qui
ont qui on qui qui ont eu lieu je dire
au niveau de d'environnement par exemple
il y a d'autres qui vont qui vont suivre
et ve dire euh tout cela demande
également évidemment dire un budget qui
est de 100 millions d'euros dont ve dire
une 40 % on ve dire est dévolué dire aux
Affaires étrangères 15 millions qui
iront qui iront dire à la police pour la
sécurité euh et le reste qui est dire
diffuser ve dire aux différents
organisateurs je dirais dire ministère
euh euh impliqué dans la l'organisation
de cette euh de cette présidence euh une
présidence qui devrait ve dire
euh connaître ve dire quelques moments
fort ve dire il y aura d'abord le le
Conseil européen veut dire le 1er
février veut dire euh puis il y aura
encore un conseil informel et puis le le
Conseil veut dire euh de de juin veut
dire où sera débattu également dire
l'agenda stratégique veut dire qui
mettra en quelque sorte dire les jalons
pour le débat dire la direction future
de l'Union européenne non seulement dire
en ve dire en déterminant les priorités
pour la mandature suivante dire dire
2024 dire
2029 euh puisque nous savons que après
les élections on aura également la
formation d'une Dee nouvelle commission
désignation dire d'un d'un nouveau
bureau du Parlement européen dire et
ainsi que je ve dire la désignation ve
dire du du nouveau président du Conseil
européen dont je ve dire dont le le le
mandat vient également à échéance dire à
la fin de cette année
euh donc voilà ve dire nous avons
également euh ve dire un un test
important ve dire qui sont les élections
dire européennes ve dire euh ou là aussi
je ve dire nous allons voir ve dire euh
veux
dire de quelle manière veux dire
l'Europe vit toujours veux dire au sein
de la population européenne qu est
l'attachement ve dire aux valeurs
européennes et ve dire je crois qu'il
est important dire pour tous les
gouvernement ve dire de l'Union
européenne dire également de de de de
s'assurer que ve dire le
l'Europe
dire ve dire montre non seulement dire
qu'elle soit ve dire toujours en
construction mais qu'elle soit également
efficace ve dire afin de pouvoir gérer
des situations non seulement vous dire
de politique étrangère mais également
sur le quotidien des personnes veut dire
tout en maintenant évidemment le grand
principe de la
subsidiarité euh voilà il encore un
slide je ve dire dire voilà ve dire si
vous avez plus besoin d'information dire
nous avons évidemment un site je veux
dire
euh dire à à disposition position et
puis dire je suis dire prêt
à dire à répondre vos questions V direz
entrer en discussion avec
vous-même merci merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur avec une photo historique
là sur laquelle on peut revenir qui est
une photo du premier Conseil européen H
qui s'est réuni le 25 janvier
1958 merci beaucoup et merci d'avoir
fait un support c'est c'est pas c'est
pas commun en fait d'avoir un support
comme ça de la part de de l'ambassadeur
qui qui va être maître ici en France de
l'organisation de l'organisation belge
euh vous avez terminé par quelque chose
d'important en parlant de la
subsidiarité j'ai vu dans le slide
effectivement vous vouliez porter
quelques éléments sur le logement ce qui
nous est apparu un peu comme nouveau
mais là on est en plein cœur de la
subsidiarité alors ça s'arrête à un
pladoyer donc ça veut dire peut-être que
vous allez écrire ou dire des choses
mais voilà comment c'est comment c'est
décliné cette cette vision d'une action
européenne sur le logement euh là dire
en fait dire nous savons que dire il y a
au niveau de logement dire y a d'abord
il y a une pinuie de logement dans
certains pays mais deuxièmement
également dire le besoin de transition
de ces logements dire les les logements
dire dire anciens ne sont plus vraiment
adaptés dire à la au défi écologique que
nous avons actuellement et donc dire par
exemple en Belgique dire nous avons des
systèmes de par lesquels les gens sont
obligés de de mettre en ordre dire la
maison dire aux normes écologiques veut
dire donc isolation dire des fenêtres
des toits dire parfois des façades dire
doncilà mais là aussi ve dire ce sont
des ce sont des suggestion que nous
faisons vous dire des méthodes de
travail que nous avons mis en place et
d'ailleurs également en en pleine
subsidarité en Belgique puisque ve dire
c'est une affaire régionale et donc ce
sont les régions qui ve dire qui mettent
en place ve dire ces systèmes mais
également les les aides dire au au ve
dire au
euh dire aux rénovations dire
nécessaires euh également dire en ce qui
concerne la construction de de de des
nouveaux bureaux de nouveaux logements
ve dire de nouvelles maisons ve dire euh
c'est important euh également en ce qui
concerne ve dire par exemple
l'aménagement du territoire dire là
aussi il est important que ve dire on
puisse dire gérer le territoire de telle
manière que ve dire on puisse ve dire
éviter ve dire des zones inondées ve
dire ou à inondation ve dire mais
également ve dire de faire en sorte que
ve dire
les les centres
les il y a une concentration dire de de
logement ou d'activités urbaines dire
dans certains endroits afin d'également
pouvoir dire euh privilégier dire accès
dire par transport
public merci euh on passe aux questions
oui donc Didier Marie Martha de Sidra
qui a Catherine main de sa bah tout le
monde voilà ok bon
allez louis- Jean aussi d'accord
bon vraiment vraiment tout le monde
estce que E pour pas me perdre vas-y
commence comme ça on va on va le faire
dans ce sens là Louis Jean tu termineras
la parole
teas allezyez bref oui merci président
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur programme
très ambitieux je je suis impressionné
pour 6 mois 6 items dont un sur lequel
je voulais vous poser une question un
peu plus précise il se trouve que je
préside une Maison de l'Europe dans les
yvelin qui est mon département votre
premier item c'est défendre l'État de
droit alors sur cet thème là justement
j'ai deux questions la première
qu'entendez-vous par défendre l'État de
droit est-ce au sein de l'Union
européenne selon vous est-ce que ça
concerne peut-être plus largement
d'autres pays notamment des candidats
futurs à l'adhésion je pense aux Balcans
occidentaux puisque nous avons nous
travaillons également sur cet aspect- là
au sein de notre commission des affaires
européennes et la deuxième question sur
le volet inclusion des citoyens donc
autonomisation je crois que c'est comme
ça que vous l'avez identifié les maisons
de l'Europe des ivelines ont également
cette ce sujet-l dans leur cahier de
charge donc est-ce que vous comptez
est-ce que vous envisagez de travailler
avec ce réseau des maisons de l'Europe
qui sont un petit peu partout en Europe
mais particulièrement en France je vous
remercie merci président merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur pour vos propos
introductifs moi
j'aurais parmi les priorités que vous
avez misise en
avant deux sujets sur lesquels je
souhaiterais revenir même si les autres
sont tout aussi intéressants le premier
concerne votre action en faveur du
climat et le projet de pacte
vert une trentaine de textes ont déjà
été adoptés euh certains malheureusement
euh ont vu leur portée euh réduite euh
je pense en particulier euh au texte sur
les produits chimiques dangereux qui a
été abandonnés sur les systèmes
alimentaires durables et vous allez euh
devoir euh porter euh deux textes
particulièrement euh importants sur la
qualité de l'air et l'autre sur les
emballages
euh pouvez-vous nous dire d'une part si
vous envisagez de réintro produire des
discussions sur les textes qui ont été
mis de côté et deuxièmement quelles sont
vos ambitions pour les deux textes qui
restent en suspens et qui devrai être
adoptés
d'ici le mois d'avril dans le même
esprit la Commission a lancé les travaux
pour définir une nouvelle cible de
réduction des émissions nettes de gaz à
effet de serre à l'horizon 2040 euh
étape intermédiaire avant le stade de
neutralité climatique en 2050 est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire là si euh la
présidence belge a déjà euh une idée du
niveau de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre qu'elle souhaiterait voir adopté
mon deuxième sujet euh très important
concerne votre euh volonté de réactiver
l'Europe sociale vous avez prévu le 31
janvier un sommet social avec les
partenaires sociaux euh à valduchess euh
parmi les textes sociaux attendus il y a
celui sur la directive des travailleurs
des plateformes qui concerne à peu près
28 millions d'Européens 5,5 directement
qui pourraiit en bénéficier or ce texte
a fait l'objet d'un blocage notamment de
la
France qui limite la portée de la
présomption légale de salariat et donc
je voulais savoir quelle était votre
position sur ce sujet et quelles étaient
les modalités que vous alliez utiliser
pour essayer de relancer les discussions
et aboutir à un texte ambitieux voilà je
vous
remercie cl
oui merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci pour cette
présentation fort ambitieuse alors moi
je vais me limiter également à à deux
questions la première question sur la
sécurité puisque vous avez parlé du
terrorisme et de
l'extrémisme violent euh
nous savons que N l'Europe est sujette à
l'arrivée ou le retour de ce terrorisme
avec ce qui se passe notamment au Proche
Orient quel est comment vous voyez ça
[Musique]
au pouvezous nous donner un peu plus de
détails sur ce point du du programme et
puis l'autre question concerne la
position de très rcente promouvoir une
Europe mondiale et là que face aux
États-Unis et aux autres puissances
comment vous voyez cette Europe mondiale
et ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faut aussi
pour si on veut une Europe mondiale une
armée
européenne oui oui oui parce que ça
fait
très bien merci beaucoup
pour ces questions très intéressantes et
parfois très
technique d'abord dire évidemment dire
d'abord j'aurais dû commencer par ça une
présidence dire ça veut pas dire que ve
dire on a dire dans toutes les matières
dire une droit d'initiative on peut
pousser certaines choses dire mais là
dire le rôle de la présidence dans son
état actuel est plutôt de essayer de
faire en sorte qu'on arrive à des
accords au niveau européen et donc ça
demande beaucoup
de tout à fait et donc dire comme il y
avait marqué dans un des trucs honest
broker c'est-à-dire que dire doit dire
en quelque sorte je veux pas dire
oublier dire c'est ses intérêts ve dire
mais de les mettre aussi dire de se
mettre dire au service ve dire ve dire
de tout le monde afin de pouvoir trouver
une solution et alors là dire dans le
cadre et dans cette période actuelle
nous aurons nous disposerons pas des 6
mois qu' les autres on a que dire TR 4
mois dire pour arriver et donc dire dans
le cadre de cette dire de
cette de cette procédure il y a les
trilogues dire dire les trilogues qui
font que dire dire présidence commission
dire dire et conseil discute dire avec
le Parlement Parlement EUR
parfois dire on arrive à avoir des
accords parfois on y arrive pas et donc
dire il y a des négociations qui doivent
se faire et là dire et je dire que ça a
été vé très apprécié par nous ça a été
également extrêmement instructif et et
fructif dans ce sens que veut dire nous
avons déjà été associés comme présidence
entrante dire par ou présidence suivante
par la présidence espagnole donc c'est
veà dire que le 1er janvier on na pas
hérité les dossiers en onité les
dossiers mais qui qui nous était connu
puisque et donc on connaît également la
façon que ça a été négocié quels sont
les point de vue de l'un et l'autre et
donc le 1er janvier on n pas dû
apprendre quelque chose de nouveau on
était déjà là dire on connaît les
dynamiques dans les différentes
institutions et donc c'est notre notre
notre volonté dire notre ambition de
pouvoir pousser dire un grand nom
dire le plus grand nombre de ces
initiatives législatives dire au
Parlement et donc lorsque vous parlez
dire de des
tro
euh de ces TR ve
dire pièces
l'tiative dire c'est notre ambition de
pouvoir dire les les porter à
ça à à une conclusion ve dire et un vote
dire positif au sein du ve dire du
Parlement européen
euh et pour cela
dire nous nous négocions et nous
négocions également sur dire différents
euh dans différents enceintes que ce
soit à Bruxelles groupe de travail que
ce soit au niveau du Conseil ministériel
et même des démarches dire euh disons
de la part ve
dire de de la présidence que ce soit le
ministre ve dire que ce soit dire ses
cabinets ve dire que ce soit moi-même ou
mes collaborateurs coporatrices dire à
parler ve dire au ve dire au ministère
et au ministre dire dire compétent et
donc dire vous avez parler dire du du
plateforme en effet ve dire c dire un
point d'AC actualité dire il y a eu des
discussions hier il y a un corupère du
euh du 24 où on doit
arriver dire à un accord afin de pouvoir
encore démarrer le trilogue le 30
janvier
pour garantir une adoption de cette
réglementation ve dire avant la fin de
cette mandature et là en effet je veux
dire ben nous sommes en discussion avec
dire les instances françaises ve dire
compétentes
dire afin de pouvoir
euh ve dire trouver une solution dire il
y a des
pistes qui sont là dire qui sont testés
en ce moment pour arriver là
dire faut dire que dire le changement
maniment ministériel n'a pas n'a pas
vraiment aidé puisque dire ben il y a eu
dire un nouveau dire une nouvelle
titulaire dire donc dire il faut
reconstruire les contacts dire la
confiance et ainsi de suite dire mais
dire nous nous attelons direz on va voir
vous dire si on on arrive à à trouver un
accord euh par rapport à l'état de droit
dire votre question dire là évidemment
nous sommes dans un processus ve dire
qui est là depuis un certain temps
euh dire le l'État de droit dire pas
c'est un processus qui est m en place
dire vis-à-vis de la Hongrie ve dire
vis-à-vis de la Pologne dire il y a des
décisions qui sont pris des propositions
qui sont faites veux dire euh et donc
nous continuons à suivre cela dire dire
en apportant notre notre notre concours
je ve dire aux négociations ve dire
autour de cette dire de ces déclarations
de ces des de ces évolutions dire euh
mais il reste important que dire nos
valeurs d'État de droit droit de
démocratie je ve dire reste reste je ve
dire intact et euh euh
euh reste ve dire également ve dire un
dire le le le critère de jugement ve
dire par rapport au au aux autres dire
dire surtout les candidats les pays
candidats qui sont là dire dire en
décembre on a ouvert ve dire la porte ve
dire euh ve dire euh
dire pour démarrer les négociations dire
vis-à-vis de la la Moldavie l'Ukraine ve
dire encore un petit peu pour la
bosnieovine ve dire euh ou il y a
certaines dire euh notamment en matière
d'état de droit dire certaines certaines
questions et pour lequel dire nous
allons faire un également un rapport ve
dire pour voir si on arrive ve dire à
arriver veut dire à une situation dire
de
de une position de pouvoir démarrer les
les le début des négociation négociation
qui dure toujours un certain temps qui
passe par certaines étapes mais qui
reste important dire et et donc l'état
de droit vous dire B c'est comme les les
critères de copenhag vous dire c'est un
des un des principes qui sont là et qui
sont évement dire évidemment dire retenu
également dans le cadre de cette de
cette négociation euh qui va avoir lieu
euh dans dans le
futur l'autonomisation vous ve dire en
fait ça veut dire et là je reviens je je
reviens sur Val du chess dire oui voilà
Vald chess c'est veut dire en fait ve
dire
euh le premier slide que je vous ai
montré dans nos priorités c'était vir de
mieux protéger les citoyens ve dire et
en fait ve dire parce que il y a ce ce
ce
euh cet écart qui
qui qui est là ou qui est ressenti comme
comme étant là par beaucoup de citoyens
ve dire de cette
Europe parfois absente distante ve dire
et imposant certaines certaines
certaines règles donc ce que nous
voulons faire ve dire c'est également
dire de de faire en sorte dire ou de de
promouvoir dire un discours
et une action que ve dire
euh le
citoyen se retrouve également ve dire se
Réconc en quelque sorte avec l'Europe
dire en en pouvoir en pouvant en ve dire
en garantissant ses droits sociaux ve
dire ve dire dire ve dire sa sa
situation ve dire dire euh euh dire
social dire au niveau de logement au
niveau de euh dans le point ve dire et
pour que ve dire euh ces personnes
soient également
dire traité de manière équitable dire
devant dire tous les autres citoyens euh
européens euh nous savons que ve dire
dans dans le passé il y a eu des des
problèmes où il y a eu des distorsions
de March sur le marché de travail veux
dire et donc ve dire là aussi dire il
est important que nous travaillons ve
dire à pouvoir ve dire euh euh euh euh
de maintenir cette ve dire cette idée de
mobilité de de des travailleurs mais
également de pouvoir dire donner les
garanties les garanties que ve dire ces
travailleurs ve dire ne se font pas
concurrence dire d'un côté à l'autre et
donc d'avoir des des des euh des des
seuils de protection sociale dire de
revenus ve dire qui soient égaux pour
tout le monde ve dire euh dans qui
travaillent dans cette même zone de de
de l'Union européenne
euh par rapport à la la sécurité veux
dire le retour du terrorisme euh en
effet veux dire euh je crois que ça
reste dire malgré dire les tensions
actuelles ailleurs ça restera dire
toujours en point d'attention pour ve
dire toutes les euh pour toutes les ve
dire toutes les présidences dire à venir
et donc ve dire là veut dire la Belgique
ve dire travaille également sur
proposition de la Commission
euh à faire ve dire à trouver dire une
des des meilleurs mécanismes de partage
d'information entre les différents
services dire
euh
et qu'on puisse également dire
travailler dire et là dire on on on
prend comme exemple dire la très bonne
dire collaboration qui existe entre la
la Belgique et la France euh où là a un
partage dire entre les services de
police entre les services de
renseignement ve dire pour ve dire et
les parquets pour échanger des choses
dire cela existe pas dire c'est sur base
dire de d'instruments bilatéraux que
nous le faisons que la France ou la
Belgique le font également avec d'autres
pays mais il y a pas un
cadre régional pardon européen qui qui
qui gère cela nous avons également les
instruments deopo dire qui sont et re
justes qui sont là qui méritent d'être
renforcés dans leur rôle afin de pouvoir
dire fluidifier et sécuriser également
dire le le le partage des informations
qui sont là et donc dire
voilà la modeste dire ambition dire de
de de de laabisique c'est de pouvoir
continuer également de travailler dans
cette zone dire dans cette zone là et de
convaincre dire le le plus plus de
de de pays à à s'adhérer dire à ces à
ces systèmes de de partage en
garantissant évidemment dire la sécurité
ve dire dire dire des
informations également au niveau de
du des exigences gdpr veut dire la
protection de la vie privée des
personnes alors les États-Unis veut dire
B
oui nous avons beaucoup de d'élections
cette année je ve dire en Europe dire en
Russie mais également aux États-Unis et
donc ve dire je crois que dire
euh nous avons quand même dire je crois
euh compris que je ve dire il dire il
faut il faut on est mieux servi par
soi-même je ve dire dans tout toutes
sortes de matières et donc ve dire que
là aussi veux dire le la construction
d'une armée européenne dire est
important ve dire je crois que ça se
fait en plusieurs stades dire dire
d'abord dire il y a également dire et
nous l'avons vu avec ve dire la
crise en Ukraine
euh il y a d'abord une une un besoin
dire de de réarmement dire réarmement ve
dire ve dire au au niveau européen ve
dire et donc ve dire c'est pour cela
aussi qu'il faut dire mettre en place
dire des systèmes dire européens ve dire
de de de Cré de capacité dire de
de d'armement afin de de ne pas dépendre
dire des des des parties tierces dire
pour nous armer dire et donc au niveau
ve
dire de l'armée européenne en tant que
tel dire il y a plusieurs idées dire qui
sont là même déjà plusieurs activités
qui se qui se mett en
place mais je crois que vir là éalement
dire ben nous sommes également sur un
terrain veut dire où beaucoup de pays ve
dire jouent également dire la carte de
la souverainité dire et donc ve dire là
il y a évidemment ve dire des choses à
voir et peut-être ve
dire que que les événements dire
extérieur vont nous pousser dire dire à
avancer dans cette idée
euh sachant qu'on que par le billet ve
dire des instruments européens déjà en
place on peut déjà faire beaucoup ce qui
concerne dire le European Peace Facility
dire la facilité européenne de paix veut
dire ce qui concerne dire toutes sortes
de Miss de mission que nous
avons mission dire
civilire à
l'étranger notre l'aide humanitaire qui
est également dire mise en place veut
dire dans certaines zones dire qui
également dire gérer coordonn ve dire au
niveau européen et donc dire tout ça
sont des des des outils qui qui peuvent
nous mener à une une une action ve dire
dire peut-être plus vigoureuse on ve
dire au niveau
européen euh voilà dire en ce qui
concerne vos questions dire monsieur le
sénateur ve dire voilà qui sont très
spécifiques dire j'ai pas les réponses
dire euh à savoir quel est le le niveau
qu'on aait avoir au niveau des effets de
C dire je dispose pas des des
renseignements dire je peux les les
fournir peut-être à un moment
plus merci très petite dem vraiment très
petite
donc merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous
vous avez pointé du doigt à juste titre
que dans votre programme vous allez vous
préoccuper de contribuer à ce que
l'Europe retrouve son autonomie
stratégique
euh par le BIA notamment du
développement d'un écosystème durable et
efficace pour le pour le numérique alors
il y a les textes de règlement le
triptique DMA DSA l'IA acte est en cours
de finalisation pouvez-vous nous dire où
on en est dans ce calendrier de
finalisation d'un texte extrêmement
important extrêmement débattu en France
mais pas qu'en France avec un équilibre
nous l'espérons assurer entre innovation
et transparence parce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de débats là-dessus c'est
fondamental s'agissant de la
consolidation de l'écosystème numérique
pouvez-vous nous dire justement comment
la la la Belgique va insister fortement
à ce qu'il y a une vraie politique
industrielle qui se met en place euh
pour moi encore assez déficiente surtout
à sortie d'une redéfinition des
conditions générales de concurrence
comme vous l'avez expliqué euh plus
loyal et plus facilitatrice pour nos
entreprises européennes ce qui n'est
toujours pas le cas d'ailleurs le Data
ACT va poser la question des avantages
euh acquis des grandes plateformes
américaine qui reste assez outrancière
donc pour réduire nos dépendances faut
avant tout soutenir le dévelppement d'un
écosystème européen de manière
préférentielle et quelle mesure pourrait
être adopté dans un Data un Small
Business Act un by Europan Act y y
a-t-il des réflexions là-dessus qui
peuvent
être poussées car tout ceci réguler cet
écosystème numérique c'est garantir le
le pluralisme que vous évoquez Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur le pluraliste notamment
des médias qui assure la la démocratie
un autre texte d'ailleurs qui est celui
du Freedom media Act est en en cours de
finalisation on est également le
calendrier de finalisation nous avions
été extrêmement attentifs avec mes
collègues à aux questions de
subsidiarité aussi respecté euh par ce
texte donc j'aimerais avoir votre point
de vue là-dessus et puis j'ai une
dernière question qui est un peu une
taquinerie je regardez le slogan
B eu ou voilà je trouve très très
astucieux je dois dire mais je ne peux
m'empêcher en cette année où en France
nous allons fêter les 40 ans de la loi
TOUTBON à m'interroger quand même
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas ne va-on pas
apparaître les trois langues officielles
de de l'Europe l'allemand le français
vous êtes un pays francophone et je
formule le veœux que vraiment le
pluralisme des médias la diversité
culturelle ça passe aussi par le respect
de la diversité linguistique et le
respect des langues officielles de
l'Europe de tant que le Royaume-Uni a
quitté l'Union européenne C il reste
Malte l'Irlande qui parle anglais mais
mais tout de même je pense qu' la
diversité culturelle c'est la diversité
linguistique donc nous avons à la
promouvoir voilà Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je voulez vous alerter sur ce petit
point
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur deux petites
questions aussi de mon côté tout d'abord
une première sur la réforme de l'UE il y
aura un sommet de l'élargissement qui
est prévu le 19 avril pour célébrer le
20e anniversaire de l'élargissement de
2004 et ce sera aussi l'occasion
d'avancer sur la réforme de l'Union euh
il a été insisté sur le fait que la
discussion ne porterait pas sur le vote
à l'unanimité et l'extension de
l'utilisation du vote à la majorité
qualifiée ni sur la composition des
commissaires mais sur des mesures plus
consensuelles et est-ce que vous
pourriez nous donner quelques éléments
sur les mesures sur lesquelles la
présidence belge souhaite travailler
dans le cadre de cette de ce de ce
sommet sur l'élargissement et puis
revenir sur le le le Green Deal euh la
la Belgique devrait être en mesure de de
de de porter les priorités du Green Deal
lors de l'élaboration du programme
stratégique quinquenal du Conseil
européen est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner plus d'éléments sur les
propositions de la présidence que la
présidence souhaite mettre en avant
euh dans le cadre de ce programme
stratégique en lien avec le pacte
vert voilà c'est
tout merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur parmi les grands
chantiers les grands sujets je souhaite
également évoquer celui d'élargissement
de l'Union européenne à de nouveaux
États-membres avec aujourd'hui deux
positions distinctes au sein du du
Conseil de l'Union européenne des
États-membres qui aujourd'hui souhaitent
d'abord une réforme profonde des
institutions de l'Union européenne avant
d'ouvrir les négociations avec de
nouveaux États-membres et puis d'autres
États qui souhaitent mener les deux en
même temps avec une priorité et surtout
prioritairement avec l'Ukraine et la
Moldavie quel est alors est-ce que vous
pourriez rappeler la position de la
Belgique et surtout votre ambition en la
matière tout en sachant ou tout en
rappelant que la prochaine présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne sera
exercée par la Hongrie dont on connaît
les positions et puis une autre mais pas
forcément question mais remarques j'ai
aussi
entendu vos ambitions en matière de
logement et plus largement d'aménagement
du territoire ambition que je partage
complètement puisque nous nous nous
avons les mêmes enjeux de pénurie de
logement de rénovation de for de
massification de la rénovation
énergétique de réduction
d'artificialisation des sols pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique donc je
serais particulièrement regardante et
surtout très en attente de de savoir
sous quel angle vous souhaitez la parce
que ce sont des sujets sur lesquels
aujourd'hui nous sommes nous travaillons
particulièrement au sein du du Parlement
je vous remercie Pierre cuiper oui merci
Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur un sujet d'actualité c'est
celui de des attaques terroristes en mer
Rouge par les outis et j'aurais voulu
savoir parce que l'Europe va se trouver
très fragilisée par rapport à à ses
approvisionnements on voit d'ailleurs
qu'en Allemagne la société tels ça a
fermé son usine et qu'en Belgique la
société Volvo devrait fermer cette
semaine c'est puisque par manque
d'approvisionnement quelle position vous
voyez que l'Europe puisse prendre pour
justement compenser ou éviter ou je sais
pas enfin en tout cas trouver une
solution positive pour notre économie
merci voilà l' not
list juste d'abord j'ai une vingtaine de
questions mais j'en poserai que deux
pour euh Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci de
V votre présence moi j'ai j'ai j'ai deux
questions une première d'abord une je je
me félicite que dans ce la votre
présentation la culture rentre dans
l'Europe de façon importante euh parce
que cétait réservé jusqu'aux États
nationaux jusqu'à jusqu'à présent et je
vois que j'espère qu'il y aura une
impulsion pour que l'Europe se saisisse
de la culture européenne et et notamment
patrimonial je crois que c'est une une
bonne une bonne chose et je je vous en
félicite moi j'ai juste deux questions
euh la première est-ce que
Erasmus est-ce que le le rapprochement
Erasmus anglais euh peut avoir lieu
est-ce que la Belgique veut bien
travailler là-dessus parce que c'est
c'est quand même extrêmement important
pour nos jeunes même si le français en
effet doit être une langue importante
euh et et la
deuxème la la deuxème question c'est
qu'est-ce que la l'Europe enfin va
vis-à-vis de Taïwan et les élections qui
ont eu lieu à Taïwan dernièrement
prendre une position au même titre que
les Américains qui ont envoyé deux
personnes de deux diplomates dès le
lendemain de l'élection euh pour
maintenir la la la position de l'Europe
face face à je sais que les Allemands
sont un peu hésitants sur des prises de
position je voulais savoir si il y avait
déjà une réflexion
là-dessus
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur à
vous un large volet de de question et PE
ouais ouais mais il y en a qui se
rapprochent sur élargissement pacte vert
voà donc donc je vais peut-être essayer
de répondre en tir groupé dire
euh euh par rapport à l'élargissement
dire puis qu'il y a plusieurs questions
dire évidemment je ve dire euh là la
Belgique ve dire est ve dire euh enfin
il y a eu des discussions dire en en
dire en décembre dire par rapport à cela
dire la décision a été prise dire par
rapport euh à cette cet objectif et ve
dire nous sommes ve dire euh ve dire
dire tout à fait veux dire nous nous
inscrivons dans les dans les les
principes dire dire qui régissent
l'élargissement dire tel qu'ils ont eu
donc ça veut dire que dire une ve dire
euh ve
dire dire une une le respect des
critères de copenhag dire je ve dire un
euh dire un trajectoire de négociation
vous dire avec je ve dire la finisation
par chapitre comme on l' fait dans dans
le passé euh ve dire euh et de et d'une
attention dire particulière dire à euh
ve dire certains sujets qui prêtent pour
l'instant un peu à la dire à la
confusion ou à l'inquiétude dire par
rapport à certaines choses ve dire et
qui sont différents pour chaque pays euh
n'oublions pas non plus ve dire l'aspect
géopolitique évidemment ve dire qui qui
est là aussi dire et qui pourrait
déterminer en quelque sorte également
dire le les débats dire que nous allons
voir dire au niveau du Conseil européen
euh donc ve dire euh et là je je revient
je ve dire un peu je veux dire au niveau
macro euh dans ce sens que ve dire euh
il nous a demandé dire de préparer le
débat les les dire le le le le trajet
stratégique dire dire de l'Europe euh
veux dire donc c'est c'est quelque chose
qui va avoir lieu ve dire normalement à
la fin de notre présidence ve
dire au Conseil européen ve dire ou ve
dire la Belgique devra mettre en place
ve dire une dire des idées pour ve dire
trajectoire stratégique pour les années
à venir et donc évidemment dire c'est
non seulement sur le positionnement dire
de l'Europe dans un grand nombre de
dossiers que ce soit sur la sécurité je
ve dire sur la sécurité la défense mais
également sur la façon que nous allons
nous organiser dire non seulement à
l'heure actuelle etant 27 mai pays
membres et quelles sont les ambitions
dire afin de pouvoir aller plus plus
loin dans l'intégration ou
de de de de de remettre dire à nouveau
dire le la subsidiarité ve dire dire ve
dire en avant ve dire pour certaines
matières la deuxème chose c'est que dire
vis-à-vis ver
une ve dire une Europe
euh qui pourrait ve dire s'élargir
comment est-ce que nous allons nous nous
organiser ve dire que ce soit au niveau
de la gestion des du Conseil européen au
niveau des conseils techniques au niveau
dire du de la Commission du Parlement
européen puisque là aussi ben il faut
intégrer évidemment des parlementaires
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on reste au nombre
actuel où est-ce que on va diminuer le
nombre de personnes et tout ça sont des
choses très très ve dire très difficile
et là ve dire euh euh veux dire euh les
contacts que nous allons avoir pendant
ces 6 mois dire ben j'espère que nous
nous pouvons arriver avec une
proposition qui pourrait être adopté
dire lors de du conseil de
juin vous avez fait une référence ve
dire à la présidence suivante ve dire
évidemment ve dire la présidence
suivante aura un peu le même problème
que nous c'est-à-dire que dire c'est une
législature peu un peu bizarre dans ce
sens que dire une présidence un peu
bizarre dans ce sens que ve dire ve dire
chez eux ve dire ben le Parlement va se
réunir le Parlement européen va se
réunir le 15 dire juillet pour la
première fois dire il y a la mise en
place du bureau vous dire les votes mise
en place de la commission vous dire donc
il y a tout ça qui va se qui va se faire
et donc vous dire peut-être que ce n'est
que à partir du 1er octobre 15 octobre
15 septembre 1er octobre que la
présidence hongroise puisse vraiment
démarrer dans dans dans dans ces euh
dans ces choses
euh et je veux dire il y a
dans on connaît bien la position dire de
la Hongrie sur certains dossiers mais
sur d'autres dossiers ils sont aussi
européens que nous dire donc ils ont les
mêmes intérêts que nous et donc ils ont
également l'intérêt d'avancer dans
certains dans certains dossiers dire euh
et donc ve dire euh c'est dans ce sens-l
que veux dire nous essayons de préparer
au maximum dire dire
la la législature dire prochaine les
débats prochains dire dire qu' vont
avoir avec déjà des des des des trames
d'idées dire des trames de stratégie
qu'on autour lesquell ve dire ce débat
va avoir lieu dire c'est pas en en
juillet qu'on va décider comment
l'Europe future sera assembla mais au
moins VI les les contours seront connus
dire de ce qu'on ce qu'on peut faire
euh euh par rapport ve
dire l'industrie la politique
industrielle dire pour dire mon mon
premier ministre c'est dire un dire un
un objectif dire premier dans ce sens
qu'il a extrêmement bien compris et je
crois que les événements dire dire de
covid dire de l'Ukraine on ont vraiment
mon démontré que dire il y a
besoin dire d'une de la création d'une
autonomie stratégique ve dire ve dire
dans plusieurs domaines mais également
dire de
réindustrialiser dire la dire l'Europe
évidemment il est important que nous le
faisons également dire en respectant
dire le le le le Green Deal dire le le
le pacte vert qui a été mise en place
tout cette transition écologique et donc
nous devons également mettre dire nos
nos industries dire ou le développement
de notre fibre industrielle dire dire
également la recherche et dire le
développement dans une une situation
dire aussi
favorable dont bénéficie dire
nos partenaires concurrents ve
dire
je ve dire outre outre européen donc
veux dire il est important que je ve
dire on on arrive à trouver le juste
milieu et donc ve dire il y a plusieurs
euh
euh plusieurs choses qui sont qui ont
été lancées dire il revient également à
la présidence de veiller à ce que ve
dire euh cette cette course au subside
cette course dire au
dire au euh au au avant avantage je ve
dire à certains secteurs ne ne disrupte
pas non plus je dire
le le marché dire unique tel qu'il
existe actuellement et donc dire là
aussi nous devons voir que dire nous
nous nous aurons un leven playing field
non seulement avec dire les dire les
partenaires de l'extérieur mais ici
aussi au sein de l'Union
européenne donc ve dire les ambitions
dire au niveau du le pacte vert reste ve
dire valide dire elles ont été adoptées
dire seront ve dire mises en avant et
donc et donc voilà
[Musique]
euh ve
dire il il reste ve dire encore
plusieurs choses à faire dire c'est la
la révision dire des normes de
d'émission pour dire les camions les
poids lourds
euh la révision de la
concernant dire l'emballage donc vous
avez
dire et donc ve
dire là dire c'est quelque chose que sur
lequel nous continuons à travailler dire
nous le mettrons en avant ça a été
repris comme une des priorités dans les
120 dire directive encore à adopter dire
avant la fin de dire de la de cette
mandature et la disution du Parlement
européen donc ve dire il y a il y a tous
ces chosesl dire euh mais je dire là
aussi il faut voir comment les trilogues
vont vont pouvoir se euh se se dérouler
euh par rapport ve dire à la mer Rouge
dire la question ve dire ben la
situation est en effet dire euh
euh inquiétante dire
et pourrait être ve dire très disruptif
pour l'économie euh européenne et là
dire il y a des initiatives des
discussion en cours en ce moment je dire
à Bruxelles dire sur dire la façon que
dire on
on dire
euh on se mobilise afin de pouvoir euh
euh gérer cette cette cette menace veut
dire à la à la circulation des biens ve
dire euh ve dire ve dire vers vers vers
l'Europe euh Erasmus
dire et ve dire et les Anglais ve dire
euh il y a des discussions en cours en
ce moment ve dire avec ve dire la la
Grande-Bretagne je ve dire euh vous
savez c'est pas toujours une chose
facile puisque je ve dire sont retirés
ve dire de certaines choses dire ils
sont toujours dire maintenant ils sont
ve
dire intéressés dans certains aspects
dire de notre de notre coopération dire
il y a le programme Horizon qui dire
dire le programme de recherche ve dire
auquel ils sont également intéressés et
nous avons toujours la question du
l'Irlande du Nord qui est là dire et
donc dire il y a des des discussions qui
sont actuellement en cours ve dire afin
de trouver une solution euh sachant
également que ve dire
euh il y aura également des élections ve
dire en Grande-Bretagne qui risquent de
de rendre les discussion un peu plus
difficil dire vu les promesses veut dire
des gouvernements britanniques euh
précédents et donc je ve dire voilà mais
mais je ve dire là ve dire
euh la présidence mais surtout la
Commission européenne travaille dire en
bonne foi dire afin de pouvoir dire
euh de pouvoir dire que même dire
trouver des solutions avec dire nos amis
euh britanniques
euh mais se rendant compte également
vous dire pas du du fait que vous dire
ben le brexit a eu des conséquences dire
et dire que les Britanniques doivent
également dire euh accepter les les
comment dire le les conséquences de leur
décision dire de quitter l'un européenne
donc voilà mais ça n'empêche pas dire la
possibilité de d'ouverture et l'accès à
certains programmes dire au niveau enfin
ça ve dire une fois que ces choses
seront discutées
euh inelligence artificielle ah
intelligence artificielle dire et là je
dois lire un peu parce que vous dire
c'est une question très spécifique et
dire
voilà nous sommes ve dire nous sommes
contents du du compromis qui a été
trouvé dire entre le Conseil et le
Parlement euh on sait que dire les les
trilogues dire avec le parl n'ont pas
toujours a été très facile ve dire euh
également parce qu'il y a eu cette dire
euh euh
dire les développements dire
spectaculaires au niveau de ve dire de
l'intelligence artificielle nous voulons
que dire il y ait un un équilibre entre
dire innovation et dire régulation
euh également dire
dire tout en garantissant on veut dire
dire dire des des applications
économiques
euh
euh mais également ve dire en ayant
attention ve dire ve dire à la dire la
protection de la vie privée ve dire dire
des dire de nos
citoyens euh et également ve dire à cela
dire de faire en sorte également dire de
nous prémunir de de toute utilisation
dire fautil ou abusif d'intelligence
artificielle dans tout ce qui est ve
dire désinformation ve dire dire dire
qui pourrait également dire et ça c'est
non seulement au niveau de de
l'intelligence artificielle mais
également au niveau dire des
dire des médias sociaux comme nous le
connaissons et donc dire oui pour la
liberté dire dire des médias dire
d'avoir une une diversité donc dans les
dans le pays visage médiatique ve
dire mais également dire avec quand même
dire dire des des des des supervisions à
ce que ve dire dire ceci ne soit pas
dire
la dire une possibilité dire de de de de
de désinformer dire dire le le la
politique et pour faire pour terminer la
culture ve dire je sais que la culture
ve dire est quelque chose ve dire euh
d'important dire au niveau européen ve
dire euh notre notre nos ministres de la
Culture puisque ve dire en Belgique veut
dire euh la culture tout comme ve dire
euh l'éducation ve dire euh dire par
exemple le patrimoine veut dire sont des
des matières sont entre autres des
matières veut dire euh régionalisé et
donc dire là nos ministres de la Culture
sont extrêmement importants de pouvoir
de de de vouloir dire mettre en avant
dire certaines choses afin de de de de
faire en sorte que ve dire nos nos
cultures et nos spécificité culturelle
puisse également dire euh continuer et
dans ce cadre là ve dire sur
la la nécessité de de défendre ve dire
le français au sein de l'Union
européenne dire je peux vous garantir
que que nous le faisons dire moi-même je
suis néirlandophone ve dire je vous
parle en
français ile aussi tout à fait donc ve
dire euh nous le faisons ve dire là dire
la Belgique a choisi ve dire ce ce logo
là ve dire euh c'est un logo ve dire qui
a été dire adopté dire au Conseil
minunicériel dire en Belgique mais qui
ve dire malgré ve dire ve dire ve dire
parce que dire à l' pasque dire il y a
également d'autres pays qui ont utilisé
plutôt leur leur nom nirland anglais euh
euh donc on reste dans ce même ce même
schéma euh mais ve dire évidemment ve
dire en respectant tout à fait ve dire
ve dire la dire l'utilisation de nos nos
trois langues
nationales
voilà voilà monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur et en plus on on termine
dans les temps donc peut-être au plaisir
de de vous rencontrer à nouveau je sais
on fait une on a une réunion avec les
ambassadeurs après les questions
d'actualité mais je pense que vous aviez
décliner probablement euh oui parce que
un autre ouais ouais avec tous les
ambassadeurs de l'Union justement sur
l'élargissement ah ouais ouis donc on va
voir l'avis de chacun sur la question h
très bien je suis désolé beau non
non